pour obtenir son avis.
C'est comme ça que j'ai fini par déjeuner avec les scientologues.
C'était un homme appelé Brian
qui dirige une équipe de cracks scientologues
qui sont déterminés à détruire la psychiatrie partout où elle se trouve.
On les appelle le CCHR.
Et je lui ai dit, « Pouvez-vous me prouver
que la psychiatrie est une pseudo-science à laquelle on ne peut pas faire confiance ? »
Et il dit: « Oui, nous pouvons vous le prouver. »
Et j'ai dit, « Comment ? »
Et il répondu : « Nous allons vous présenter Tony. »
J'ai dit, « Qui est Tony ? »
Il a répondu, «Tony est à Broadmoor. »
Broadmoor est maintenant Broadmoor Hospital.
Avant, c'était l'asile de Broadmoor pour les fous criminels.
C'est là qu'on envoie les tueurs en série
et les gens qui ne peuvent pas se contrôler.
Et j'ai dit à Brian, « Qu'a fait Tony ? »
Il a répondu, « Presque rien.
Il a tabassé quelqu'un ou quelque chose comme ça,
et il a décidé de simuler la folie pour échapper à la prison.
Mais il l'a trop bien simulée, et maintenant il est coincé à Broadmoor
et personne ne croira qu'il est sain d'esprit.
Voulez-vous qu'on essaye de vous faire entrer à Broadmoor pour rencontrer Tony? »
J'ai dis : « Oui, merci. »
J'ai donc pris le train pour Broadmoor.
J'ai commencé à bâiller incontrôlablement vers Kempton Park,
c'est apparemment que les chiens font aussi lorsque ils sont anxieux --
ils bâillent incontrôlablement.
Et nous sommes arrivés à Broadmoor.
Et on m'a fait passer une porte après l'autre
jusqu'au Centre de bien-être,
l'endroit où vous rencontrez les patients.
Ça ressemble à un Hampton Inn géant.
Tout est décoré de bois de pin de couleur pêche ou autres couleurs apaisantes.
La seule couleur qui attire l'attention, c'est le rouge des boutons de panique.
Et les patients ont fait leur apparition.
Ils avaient tous quelques kilos en trop et portaient des pantalons de jogging
affichant un regard bien docile.
Et Brian le scientologue a chuchoté a mon oreille,
"Ils sont sous l'effet de médicaments,"
ce qui, pour un scientologue, représente le mal incarné,
mais je pense que c'est probablement une bonne idée.
(Rires)
Et puis, Brian dit: « Voici Tony. »
Un homme est entré.
Il n'était pas gros, il était en très bonne forme physique.
Il ne portait pas de pantalon de survêtement,
il portait un costume à rayures.
Il tendait les bras
comme s'il sortait de l'émission The Apprentice.
Il ressemblait à un homme qui voulait porter un costume
qui irait me convaincre qu'il était très sain d'esprit.
Et il s'est assis.
Et j'ai dit, « C'est vrai que vous avez simulé pour entrer ici ? »
Et il a répondu : « Oui. Oui. Absolument. J'ai tabassé quelqu'un quand j'avais 17.ans.
J'étais en prison en attendant mon procès,
et mon compagnon de cellule m'a dit :
« Tu sais ce que tu dois faire ?
Simuler la folie.
Dis-leur que tu es fou. On t'enverra dans un hôpital confortable.
Les infirmières t'apporteront des pizzas.
Tu auras ta propre Playstation. » »
Alors j'ai dit, « Et tu as fait comment ? »
Il a répondu : « J'ai demandé à voir le psychiatre de la prison.
Je venais de voir un film intitulé « Crash »
dans lequel des gens ont du plaisir sexuel à écraser des voitures dans les murs.
Alors j'ai dit au psychiatre,
« J'ai du plaisir sexuel à écraser des voitures dans les murs. » »
J'ai dit, « Quoi d'autre? »
Il a répondu : « Oh, oui. J'ai dit au psychiatre
que je voulais regarder les femmes mourir
parce que ça me ferait sentir plus normal. »
Et j'ai dit, « D'où tu tires ça ? »
Il a répondu , « Oh, d'une biographie de Ted Bundy
qu'ils avaient à la bibliothèque de la prison. »
En bref, il feignait la folie trop bien, disait-il.
Et ils ne l'ont pas envoyé dans un hôpital confortable.
Ils l'ont envoyé à Broadmoor.
Dès qu'il y est entré,
il a dit qu'il a jeté un coup d'œil à l'endroit, a demandé à voir le psychiatre,
et a dit, « Il y a eu un terrible malentendu.
Je n'ai pas de troubles mentaux. »
J'ai dit, « Depuis combien de temps es-tu ici ? »
Il a répondu, « Eh bien, si j'avais purgé toute la peine pourle crime que j'ai commis au départ,
j'aurais fait cinq ans.
Je suis à Broadmoor depuis 12 ans. »
Tony a dit qu'il est beaucoup plus difficile de convaincre les gens que vous êtes sain d'esprit
plutôt que de les convaincre que vous êtes fou.
Il a dit : « Je pensais que le meilleur moyen de paraître normal
serait de parler aux gens normalement des choses normales
comme de football ou de ce qu'il y a à la télé.
Je suis abonné au New Scientist,
et récemment il a eu un article
sur comment l'armée américaine entrainait des bourdons à flairer des explosifs.
Alors j'ai dit à une infirmière,
« Vous saviez que l'armée américaine entraine des bourdons
à flairer des explosifs ? »
Lorsque j'ai lu mes notes médicales,
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient écrit :
« Croit que les abeilles peuvent flairer les explosifs. »
Il a dit : « Tu sais, ils cherchent toujours
des indices non verbaux de mon état d'esprit.
Mais comment s'asseoir de manière saine ?
Comment coiser les jambes de manière saine ?
C'est juste impossible. »
Et quand Tony qui m'a dit ça,
je me suis dit, « Est-ce que je suis assis comme un journaliste ?
Est-ce que je croise mes jambes comme un journaliste ? »
Il a dit : « Vous savez, j'ai l'étrangleur de Stockwell à ma droite
et j'ai le violeur des tulipes à ma gauche.
Donc j'ai tendance à rester beaucoup dans ma chambre parce que je les trouve assez effrayant.
Et ils prennent ça comme un signe de folie.
Ils disent que ça prouve que je suis distant et grandiose. »
Il n'y a qu'à Broadmoor où ne pas vouloir passer du temps avec des tueurs en série
est un signe de folie.
De toute façon il m'a semblé tout à fait normal , mais qu'est-ce que j'y connais ?
Quand je suis rentré chez moi, j'ai envoyé un email à son clinicien, Anthony Maden.
J'ai dit, « C'est quoi l'histoire? »
Et il a répondu : « Oui. Nous acceptons que Tony ait simulé la folie pour échapper à une peine de prison
parce que ses hallucinations qui avaient semblé assez cliché à première vue
ont disparu à la minute où il est arrivé à Broadmoor.
Cependant, nous l'avons évalué.
Et nous avons déterminé que c'était un psychopathe. »
En fait, feindre la folie
est exactement le genre d'action rusée et manipulatrice propre à un psychopathe.
C'est sur la liste de vérification : rusé et manipulateur.
Feindre que votre cerveau va mal
est la preuve que votre cerveau va mal.
Et j'ai parlé à d'autres experts,
et ils ont dit le costume à rayures, c'est typique du psychopathe.
Ça renvoie aux articles 1 et 2 sur la liste de vérification :
le bagou, le charme superficiel et une estime de soi grandiose .
J'ai dit, « Et puis quoi, il ne voulait à passer du temps avec les autres patients ? »
Typique du psychopathe, ça renvoit à la folie des grandeurs et aussi au manque d'empathie.
Toutes les choses qui avaient semblé tout à fait normales chez Tony
étaient des preuves, selon son médecin,
qu'il était fou de cette nouvelle manière.
C'était un psychopathe.
Et son médecin m'a dit :
« Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les psychopathes,
vous pouvez assister à un cours pour apprendre à repérer les psychopathes
dirigé par Robert Hare, celui qui a inventé la liste de vérification pour psychopathe ».
Donc je l'ai fait.
je suis allé à un cours de repérage de psychopathe,
et je suis maintenant certifié,
et je dois dire, extrêmement habile,
en ce qui concerne le repérage des psychopathes.
Voici donc quelques statistiques :
Une personne ordinaire sur 100 est un psychopathe.
Il y a 1 500 personnes dans cette salle
Quinze d'entre vous sont des psychopathes.
Bien que ce chiffre s'élève à 4 %
parmi les PDG et autres chefs d'entreprise.
Donc je pense qu'il y de grandes chances
qu'il y ait 30 ou 40 psychopathes dans cette salle.
Il pourrait y avoir un carnage avant la fin de la nuit.
(Rires) (Rires)
Hare a dit que c'est parce que le capitalisme dans sa forme la plus impitoyable
récompense le comportement psychopathe,
le manque d'empathie, le bagou,
fourbe, manipulateur.
En fait, le capitalisme, dans sa forme la plus implacable,
est une manifestation physique de la psychopathie.
C'est comme une forme de psychopathie
qui est parvenue à nous affecter tous.
Et Hare m'a dit, « Vous savez quoi ? Oubliez le type à Broadmoor
qui simule la folie ou pas.
Ça intéresse qui ? Ce n'est pas important.
Ce qui est important », a-t-il dit, « c'est la psychopathie d'entreprise.
Ce que vous devez faire, c'est aller interviewer des psychopathes d'entreprises. »
J'ai donc essayé. J'ai écrit aux gens d'Enron.
J'ai dit, « Est-ce que je pourrais venir et vous interviewer en prison
pour savoir si vous êtes psychopathes? »
Et ils n'ont pas répondu.
J'ai donc changé de tactique.
J'ai envoyé un email à Al « la tronçonneuse » Dunlap,
qui licenciait à tour de bras à partir des années 1990.
Il investissait des entreprises en faillite et licenciait 30 % des effectifs,
et transformait des villes américaines en villes fantômes.
Je lui ai envoyé un email qui disait :
« Je crois que vous avez peut-être une anomalie du cerveau très particulière
qui vous rend spécial
et intéressé par l'esprit prédateur et intrépide.
Puis-je venir vous interviewer
au sujet de votre anomalie cérébrale particulière ? »
Et il répondu , « Venez donc. »
Je suis donc allé au grand manoir de Al Dunlap en Floride
qui était rempli de sculptures d'animaux prédateurs.
Il y avait des lions et des tigres.
Il m'a fait visité le jardin.
Il y avait des faucons et des aigles.
Il me disait , « Là, vous avez des requins. »
Il disait ça d'une manière moins effeminée.
« Encore plus de requins et vous avez des tigres ».
C'était comme Narnia.
(Rires)
Et puis nous sommes allés dans sa cuisine.
On appelait Al Dunlap pour sauver les entreprises qui faisaient faillite.
Il licenciait 30 % de la main-d'œuvre.
Et il renvoyait très souvent les gens avec une note d'humour.
Par exemple, une célèbre annecdote à son sujet,
quelqu'un est venu lui dire, « Je viens de d'acheter une nouvelle voiture. »
Il a répondu : « Vous avez peut-être une nouvelle voiture,
mais je vais vous dire ce que vous n'avez pas, un emploi. »
Dans sa cuisine, il se tenait debout il avec son épouse, Judy,
et son garde du corps Sean, j'ai dit, « Vous savez que j'ai dit dans mon email
que vous avez peut-être une anomalie cérébrale particulière qui vous rend spécial ? »
Il a dit, « Oui, c'est une théorie étonnante.
C'est comme Star Trek. Tu vas là où aucun homme n'est encore allé. »
J'ai dit, « Eh bien, certains psychologues diront
que cela fait de vous... « (Marmonne)
(Rires)
Et il dit : « Quoi? »
J'ai dit, « Un psychopathe ».
J'ai dit, « J'ai une liste de caractéristiques psychopathiques dans ma poche.
Puis-je les passer en revue avec vous ? »
Et il semblait intrigué malgré lui,
et il a dit: « OK, allez-y. »
J'ai dit, "OK. Une estime de soi grandiose . »
Ce qui, je dois dire, lui aurait été difficile de nier
parce qu'il se tenait debout sous une peinture à l'huile géante de lui-même.
(Rires)
Il a dit : « Bien, Il faut croire en soi ! »
J'ai dit, « Manipulateur. »
Il a dit, « C'est ça être un leader. »
Et j'ai dit, « Emotions peu profondes :
l'incapacité de vivre une gamme d'émotions. »
Il a dit: « Qui veut être entravé par des émotions absurdes ? »
Il parcourait la check-list caractérisant le psychopathe.
en la transformant en « Qui a déplacé mon fromage? »
(Rires)
Mais j'ai remarqué une chose qui m'arrivait à moi le jour où j'étais avec Al Dunlap.
Chaque fois qu'il disait quelque chose qui était plus ou moins normal,
par exemple il a dit non à la délinquance juvénile.
Il a dit qu'il a été accepté à West Point,
et ils ne laissent pas les délinquants entrer à West Point.
Il a dit non aux nombreuses relations conjugales à court terme.
Il a n'a été marié que deux fois.
Certes, sa première femme a cité dans ses papiers de divorce
qu'une fois, il l'aurait menacée avec un couteau
et qu'il aurait dit qu'il sétait toujours demandé quel goût a la chair humaine,
mais les gens se disent des choses stupides dans un mauvais mariage, dans le feu d'une dispute
et son second mariage a duré 41 ans.
Chaque fois qu'il m'a dit quoi que ce soit qui semblait non-psychopathe,
je me suis dit, bien je vais pas le mettre dans mon livre.
Et puis j'ai pris conscience que devenir un repéreur de psychopathe
m'avait rendu un peu psychopathe.
Parce que je cherchais désespérément à le mettre dans une case marquée psychopathe.
Je voulais absolument le définir par ses angles les plus fous.
Et j'je me suis dit, oh mon Dieu. C'est ce que j'ai fait pendant 20 ans.
C'est ce que font tous les journalistes.
Nous voyageons à travers le monde avec nos blocs-notes en main,
et nous attendons les perles.
Et les perles sont toujours les aspects ultrapériphériques
de la personnalité de celui qu'on interviewe.
Et nous les assemblons comme des moines médiévaux.
Et nous décidons d'ignorer les choses normales.
Et c'est un pays qui sur-diagnostique énormément certains troubles mentaux.
Enfance bipolaire, des enfants de quatre ans à peine
sont étiquettés bipolaires
parce qu'ils font des colères,
qualifiées de bipolaires par une check-list.
Quand je suis revenu à Londres, Tony m'a téléphoné.
Il a dit: « Pourquoi ne m'avez vous pas rappelé ? »
J'ai dit, « Bien on dit que vous êtes un psychopathe. »
Et il a répondu: « Je ne suis pas un psychopathe. »
Il a dit: « Tu sais quoi, un des éléments de la check-list est le manque de remords,
mais un autre élément dans la check-list est le caractère fourbe et manipulateur.
Donc quand vous dites que vous éprouvez des remords pour votre crime,
Ils disent, ' Typique d'un psychopathe
de dire habilement qu'il a des remords lorsqu'il n'en a pas. »
C'est comme la sorcellerie. Ils retournent tout. »
Il a dit: « J'ai un procès prochainement.
Vous viendrez ? »
Alors j'ai dit d'accord.
Je suis donc allé à son procès.
Et après 14 ans de Broadmoor, ils l'ont laissé partir.
Ils ont décidé qu'il ne devrait pas rester enfermé indéfiniment
à cause d'une check-list bien remplie
qui pourraient signifier qu'il aurait une plus grande chance que la moyenne de récidiver.
Donc ils l'ont laissé partir.
Et dehors dans le couloir il m'a dit :
« Vous savez quoi, Jon ?
Tout le monde est un peu psychopathe ».
Il a dit, « Vous l'êtes. Je le suis. Bien évidemment je le suis. »
J'ai dit, « Qu'allez-vous faire maintenant ? »
Il a dit, « Je vais aller en Belgique
parce qu'il y a une femme qui me plait.
Mais elle est mariée, donc je vais devoir la séparer de son mari. »
(Rires)
De toute façon, c'était il y a deux ans
et c'est là où mon ouvrage s'est terminé.
Et pendant les 20 derniers mois, tout allait bien.
Rien de mal n'est arrivé.
Il vivait avec une fille en banlieue de Londres.
Selon Brian le scientologue,
il rattrappait le temps perdu, et je sais que ça semble inquiétant,
mais ça ne l'est pas nécessairement.
Malheureusement, au bout de 20 mois,
il est retourné en prison pendant un mois.
Il s'est retrouvé dans une bagarre dans un bar, pour utiliser ses mots,
il a fini par aller en prison pour un mois,
et je sais que c'est grave,
mais au moins une durée d'un mois implique que la bagarre quelle qu'elle ait été
n'était pas trop grave
Et puis il m'a téléphoné.
Et vous savez quoi, je pense que c'est bien que Tony soit dehors.
Parce qu'on ne devrait pas juger les gens par leurs angles les plus fous.
Et Tony, est un semi-psychopathe.
Il est une zone grise dans un monde qui n'aime pas les zones grises.
Mais c'est dans les zones grises qu'on trouve la complexité,
c'est là où on trouve l'humanité
et c'est là où on trouve la vérité.
Et Tony m'a dit :
« Jon, est-ce que je pourrais vous payer un verre dans un bar ?
Je veux vous remercier pour tout ce que vous avez fait pour moi. »
Et je n'y suis pas allé. Qu'auriez-vous fait ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)